an open door
an open window an
open bottle
open ai and github invent co-pilot and
everyone freaks out about copyright
welcome to ml news
greg brockman writes an ai pair
programmer in your editor
it's powered by open ai codex a new ai
system which can convert from natural
language to code
with increasing reliability he's talking
about github copilot
so copilot is this system uh that's
developed by openai and github to be
a super duper auto complete basically
what you do is
you write the name of a function or
some kind of a class or actually
anything you want maybe along with a
little bit of a docstring and the system
will complete
code for you now other than classical
autocomplete systems which
are rule-based and basically suggest to
you what's possible which variables fit
here which ones are in scope this system
goes
much beyond this it'll try to guess what
you're trying to do
and it will write this code for you or
it will at least suggest it so they have
a bunch of examples here for example
this
parse expenses statement the user writes
the function name
and then a few examples in the docs
string as you would write if you were to
program it
and then copilot implements the function
itself
now i've been using tab 9 for a while
and i'm pretty happy with its
suggestions especially if you pair it up
with a classic autocomplete you get the
classic autocomplete which tells you
what you
are allowed to do essentially and you
get the ai autocomplete which is trying
to guess what you want to do this
enables things like if i
catch an error that's called password
error it will already provide a log
message for me that says
password wrong and there are many more
examples where it just kind of infers
what you want to do and that's super
helpful at times copilot by github
is this on steroids it will implement
entire functions
entire classes from a description or
even just from a name of a function now
it's not going to be perfect of course
whether it actually helps or hurts and
who does it help
does it help the experienced programmer
because they can
write faster and just have to check for
errors because there
definitely are errors if you see right
here in this expense
function the money is held as a floating
point number which is a big no-no when
you handle currency
on the other hand does it help novice
programmers because
they see the implementations of
functions they wouldn't know how to
implement however
they're probably going to not catch the
mistakes there are there's a lot of
debate around this
but i'm pretty excited to see this
honestly now the issue comes
when you talk about the following they
say it's trained on billions of lines
of public code github copilot puts the
knowledge you need at your fingertips
saving you yada yada marketing however
trained on billions of lines of public
code
that means they essentially went to all
of github or the public repo
and trained a giant language model on it
it's nothing more than this it's
essentially something like gpt 3
on code probably augmented by a bit of
syntaxing and whatnot but it's not much
more
it's just lots of data lots of compute
gives you a
model of what people usually do when
prompted with some sort of strings so
safe to say this
won't replace programmers exactly
anytime soon as you can maybe see from
this
is even function implemented to extreme
precision of course and actually i don't
know if that's even uh
real or a fake because people have
definitely been making fakes about
co-pilot this is not going to happen
anytime soon what's more worrisome is
for example
openai co-pilot emitting personal
information such as this
openssh private key which someone left
in their repository
and now co-pilot is just regurgitating
it in fact on the
faq page github copilot says yes they
sometimes
output personal data not because they do
anything wrong
but because people left that personal
data in their repositories and the
system is trained on those repositories
and sometimes it will decide that the
most likely output
is that training sample and that gets us
into an interesting topic so the topic
is
does github copilot recite code from the
training set
now we've been having this discussion
for a long time do these large
language models actually understand what
they're doing or are they simply kind of
reproducing the training set
and if they reproduce the training set
by which degree do they integrate maybe
multiple training set samples
combine them or do they just take one
and kind of reformulate it a little bit
who knows github did an extensive study
in which they found that only about 0.1
of the outputs are in some way
reproductions from the training set
however there is a big dispute about
what exactly counts as a copy as a
recitation
and how different is different enough
and that gets us into the biggest
issue which is copyright so the issue
here is
that github and openai essentially take
all of this code
train their system with it and they
don't give you the co-pilot for free of
course not i mean
how are you going to live up to that
name open ai uh
they're of course going to sell this
now fair enough they did something cool
they want to make money
however um the code they used in order
to train the system
isn't always freely available at least
that's what people think now how would
you feel
if you wrote some code you were the
legal owner of the copyright to that
code and github simply trains a model on
your code and then sells that model for
other people to produce
their code and they don't have to give
you anything for it also there is the
issue
of gpl license code which requires that
any modifications to it
again become gpl licensed the question
is if
the model outputs code that was a result
of training on gpl code
does the output of the system also
become
gpl licensed or not and there is even
more of an issue
when it comes to patents on code patents
are yet another category
of intellectual property protection and
we've seen
example of co-pilot reciting
patent-protected code with all of this
i've been reading into software
copyright and whatnot a little bit and i
want to give
the disclaimer i'm not a lawyer this is
not legal advice
this is entertainment purposes only if
you want some actual opinion go to an
actual lawyer
and pay them but also what one can say
is
what lucas buyer here says with
everybody hypothesizing about co-pilot
and gpl license let me add another
perspective
nobody knows and nothing whatsoever will
happen until someone sues
someone now i'm not going to hold my
breath which is true
ultimately a judge is going to have to
decide case law has to be established
and we'll take it from there so what
follows
is my personal opinion on the matter
trying to analyze this a little bit
here's a bit of a diagram of
what's happening currently in this
system you have the
co-pilot system as a piece of software
that contains uh maybe a neural network
that has been trained on
some stuff how did this co-pilot come to
be the co-pilot is built upon libraries
such as
pytorch which are usually fairly openly
licensed like an mit license or
something like this
so there's no problem there then copilot
of course needs copilot.pie the thing
that you actually
run to do the training and the inference
which also is
authored by the co-pilot authors and
therefore not an issue in our case but
then
one of the inputs to co-pilot is of
course the giant data set
before we even get into licensing of
that data we have to talk about
copyright
itself everybody's talking about gpl
license and whatnot
but gpl being a copy left license only
pulls
if copyright law even applies so first
we have to see does copyright law even
say
anything about using this code in this
way copyright law works differently in
different countries but in general it
protects
creative outputs of people so if you do
something if you express yourself in
some creative way
you obtain automatically copyright on
that artistic
expression so if i write a song then i
am the owner of copyright for that song
i don't have to register it anywhere i
have it by default now as an owner of
copyright i get
certain benefits for example i can
decide
whether or not my work is reproduced
which derivative works can be made and
how they are treated how it is
distributed to the public how it is
performed and so on
i have certain rights to the
dissemination reproduction and
modification of my work
now notice what's not on this list
enjoying the work reading the book
reading the code
so as a copyright owner once i've
decided to display my work
publicly i can't actually prevent anyone
from
looking at it in the public space that i
chose to display it so one place we
actually have to go
is the terms of service of github so
under user generated content github says
you own content you create but you allow
us
certain rights to it in a subpoint they
say we need the legal right to do things
like host your content
publish it and share it this license
includes the right to do things
like copy it to our database make
backups
show it to you and other users parse it
into search index or
otherwise analyze it now you can debate
whether or not
otherwise analyze it means they can run
machine learning model on top of it
given that they say this is in order to
fulfill their
service but certainly you allow github
to display
your code and anyone can go on github
and you cannot prevent them from reading
your code you cannot prevent them from
actually downloading
your code to a private hard drive in
fact the ideas and algorithms behind
code are not copyrightable what's
copyrightable is only your expression of
those ideas so i can't copy your code
but i can look at your code
learn from it and then express the same
idea in my
own code if you want to protect an idea
that's the terms of patents and that's a
whole other game you actually have to
register for a patent whereas copyright
you obtain
automatically so if i can look at your
code learn from it and then reproduce
it in my own way why shouldn't a machine
be able to
and that brings us to the second
important point right here
which is the right to prepare derivative
works
based upon the work now according to
wikipedia a derivative work is an
expressive creation that includes
major copyrightable elements of an
original previously created first
work now the article here is mainly
concerned with what copyright exists on
the derivative work but for our purposes
if something is a derivative work of
something else
it is potentially in violation of the
copyright of that first
work and when is something a derivative
work if it contains
major copyrightable elements of that
original
now is this all a bit fuzzy yes
absolutely and
there is a giant gray area of course so
if i look at an algorithm
and i implement that in my own code
what counts as containing major
copyrightable elements of the original
if i use the same kind of indentations
if i use the same variable names if i
use the same structure
this isn't really an exact science it is
for judges to decide but safe to say
there is a way where i can learn from
other people's code
no matter the copyright situation and i
can then write
something based upon that and it is not
a copyright violation there is also
many situations where the exact same
thing is a copyright violation
and that all depends on how much of the
copyrightable elements so not the ideas
but the expression
of the original work is contained in the
derivative work and that of course
brings us all the way back to the
discussion
do large language models simply recite
the training data
and change it a tiny bit or do they
integrate the training data
learn from the training data learn the
patterns behind the training data and
then come up with their own way of
expressing those
patterns the truth is probably somewhere
in between they're not exactly copying
the training data but it's also not the
fact that they
understand what's behind the training
data but
safe to say there is a way where
copyright might not even apply
and then there is actually no problem
right here but let's assume for a moment
that copyright does apply and things are
actually in the realm of derivative
works well
then there are still multiple questions
right here for example here you see
that there are multiple elements in the
system one is
copilot itself as a software now if you
argue that somehow the copyrightable
elements of the input data
end up in the weights of the neural
network and therefore the neural
networks are essentially a derivative
work
of the input data then copilot itself
might be in violation
of copyright law but even if co-pilot
isn't
a violation of copyright law still the
output of co-pilot might be in violation
of copyright law
and that's going to probably have to be
decided on a case-by-case basis and it
might even be that open ai
might not be responsible for this but
the person actually using the copilot
tool to generate
output it's all a bit of a messy
situation notice what we haven't talked
about
so far gpl because gpl as i said only
applies
when copyright applies now let's assume
copyright applies so here is where we
get into licenses of code in general the
training data contains broad categories
of how code is licensed and i've listed
four of them here
there is the boring code which is so
boring that copyright doesn't apply
literally it's no expression of
creativity
it's just formulaic code writing maybe
even auto-generated
not copyrightable not a problem there
there is also the open
category which is so openly licensed
that it's usable in any format like an
mit license as long as you keep the
disclaimers there
you're fine then there is the bunch of
code that does not have a license
at all if there is no license that
essentially means
that copyright owner simply gives github
the right to publish
but retains all other copyright and
everything we said so far applies
so either copilot or the output copilot
generates or
actually both might be a violation of
the copyright
of the unlicensed code and then there is
gpl code so the gpl the
new general public license in this case
version three but
they're all kind of similar i know i
know tivolization they
are generally known as copy left
licenses because if a piece of code is
licensed
under the gpl it means that if you were
to modify this code then your
modifications also
have to be licensed under the gpl and
being licensed under the gpl
means things like if someone obtains a
copy of the software then also you have
to provide
a copy of the source code with that
software so the gpl is a bit like a
virus that
if it initially applies to a piece of
software
someone else uses that software maybe
modifies it a little bit or
includes it into their system the whole
system has to be under the gpl or they
are in violation of
the license of course if copilot is
found to be a derivative work of gpl
licensed data that would mean co-pilot
itself would fall
under the gpl and therefore openai would
have to give us
its source now what source code is is a
bit of a tricky business
in the legal scene but gpl defines it as
the preferred form of the work for
making modifications to it now
what is that exactly for open ai pilot
maybe it's not the weights of the neural
network itself because
like how can i modify them maybe it's
the training set plus
copilot dot pi maybe it's even not even
the training set but it's actually the
scraper for the training set as well as
the training code who knows now github
and openai can save themselves from
having to release the source code of
copilot if they only make it available
over the network
in which case you don't have to give out
the source code license that would only
be in the case of the agpl regardless of
that the bigger question
is what if the output of copilot is a
derivative work of gpl licensed code
in that case the output of copilot in a
case-by-case basis would also have to be
gpl licensed and who's responsible for
that
probably you as a user of copilot if you
ask copilot for code you get an output i
don't think it matters whether or not
you know that it's a derivative work of
some gpl licensed code if you then
use that code and build upon it and
maybe sell software based on it
that software technically is under the
gpl
so this was my little take on the
copyright situation around openai
co-pilot i think it's a great tool but
you can also see it brings
a lot of difficulties with it not
necessarily technical difficulties
but difficulties from the human
environment so
let me know in the comments what you
think about the situation about
copyright
and whether i completely butchered some
of the things
thanks next news speaking of copyright
facebook ai launches a image similarity
challenge where they want you to figure
out where all the memes came from so the
challenge is essentially figuring out if
someone took
some photo and modified it in some way
and of course the reason behind all of
this
is going to be to find the original
creator of every meme so we can give
them proper
credit and glory they deserve nothing
else
no one else image matching very limited
applications don't even worry about it
next news brickette is a new app that
scans your legos and tells what you can
build from
them pictopixel is a good article about
it and shows
this demo video the app will scan your
collection of legos and then tell you
what you can do with it so you can see
it gives you a bunch of suggestions of
what to do pretty neat
now this is a really really cool app
though i wonder
the things it proposes are often made
out of maybe
20 parts and this pile has at least 500
or so
in any case if you do have an ios device
which i don't
give it a try it looks like a lot of fun
[Music]
next news in more sad news the distil
pop website is going on a break so you
might notice still
as an online journal which publishes in
a non-traditional
way they want very interactive articles
they want very visual articles
explaining something
they also publish commentaries threads
but also peer-reviewed science
the frequency of publication hasn't been
too high
from them but the things they have
published generally were
super well received so one reason they
cite is volunteer burnout
which given the high quality standards
that they have i can totally believe
this is an enormous effort to keep this
going to keep the quality high and you
know
respect for doing it this long the
article makes another point namely that
self-publication seems like the future
in most cases and i think the field
generally
agrees today's scientific progress is
more made through sharing archive
publications
and discussing them on social media than
it is through the peer review system of
conferences
so even though it's sad distill will
take a break what they're advocating for
is a better future for science and
that's a great thing
okay next news engadget writes amazon is
reportedly using algorithms to fire
flex delivery drivers so amazon being
amazon
has this huge fleet of drivers that they
don't necessarily hire it's kind of like
an uber
model where the driver has an app then
they get
essentially subcontracted for driving
stuff somewhere and these aren't few
drivers there are apparently
millions of drivers doing this now
keeping up some sort of hr department on
some sort of human contact with
millions of people is a challenge so
amazon opted to
just not do it instead they use
algorithms to
track the performance of their drivers
and if the performance sinks too low
they fire the drivers algorithmically so
the article states the frustration of
some of these drivers saying
the system can often fire workers
seemingly without good cause according
to the report one worker said her rating
fell
after she was forced to halt deliveries
due to a nail in her tire she succeeded
in boosting it to great over the next
several weeks but her account was
eventually terminated for violin
amazon's terms of service
she contested the firing but the company
wouldn't reinstate her another driver
was unable to deliver packages to an
apartment complex because it was closed
with the gate lock and the residents
wouldn't answer their phones in another
building an amazon locker failed to open
so their own system failed and they
punished their drivers for it his rating
also dropped he spent six weeks trying
to raise it only to be fired for falling
below
a prescribed level if a driver feels
they're wrongly terminated
some feel there's not much recourse
either driver must spend
200 to dispute any termination
and many have said it's not worth the
effort whenever there's an issue there
is no support said cope who is 29. it's
you
against the machine so you don't even
try now here
you could try to make a nuanced point
that these people
aren't employees that it's simply not a
practical solution to manage these as
employees that overall the system might
be
better off that a lot of drivers are
having good experiences
that this is just a necessity of
managing so many people
but but see not so long ago i wanted to
get
some amazon gift cards for my discord
admins they're doing a good job
i wanted to give them some thanks so i
tried to buy some gift cards and amazon
locked me out of my account
security reasons so i verified my
identity all good tried to buy the gift
cards again they locked me out again
verified my identity cried a third time
now they locked me out permanently
so i'm trying to contact support guess
what you have to do to contact support
login oh great guess what you have to do
to get a support contact number
log in oh great tried emailing them
nothing happened
tried calling them they say they'll fix
it they haven't fixed it for
months now they said i should make a new
account great
verify the phone number of the new
account your phone is already associated
with an account my old account has
all my collection of audio books and
ebooks on it and this is just splendid
so i definitely feel with this drivers
if it's you against the machine
amazon ranks just about second to paypal
when it comes to actual customer
support so i'm not going to make the
nuance point here screw you
amazon screw you you deserve every bit
of negative press that you're getting
here
at least when there's an issue have some
support
for your drivers who get a nail stuck in
their tire yes i'm using a journalistic
medium to settle a personal dispute
what are you gonna do about it get me my
account back
[Music]
okay next we're going to look at some
helpful libraries we should make this a
segment
helpful libraries helpful libraries
okay tensorflow introduces decision
forests
new algorithm never heard of it before
give it a try decision forests in
tensorflow
facebook habitat 3d environment to train
your autonomous robot to get you
something from the fridge
when you're just too lazy have fun with
your diabetes
try it out google research falcon trains
your game playing agent
you give it a little bit of a
demonstration it learns how to play
your game and test it for you and find
bugs
so now you don't even have to play your
game while you don't walk to the fridge
good job and lastly did you ever want to
figure out what the gradient is of your
face smashing against the wall
well now you can with google ai's brax
you can simulate physics in a
differentiable way on a tpu
really fast and in our last news
tnw writes fake science is getting faker
thanks a.i journals are retracting more
and more papers because they're not by
the authors they claim to be
now of course you always know it's a
serious article
when there is a very futuristic robot on
the picture
in the front but the article is actually
a good article talking about the rise of
ai generated papers and how there is a
massive upsurge in retractions among
scientific publications
but besides that i like the intro they
say they say of course
sometimes papers get retracted because
of the authors made an honest mistake in
the research in more than half the cases
however
it's because of academic misconduct or
fraud up until a decade ago this sort of
behavior was more or less limited
to researchers falsifying experimental
data or skewing results to favor their
theory
the more sophisticated technology has
become however the more things have
gotten a lot
more complicated so the rest of the
article talks about how people
add big names to their papers how people
generate
fake authors even how people generate
even fake papers
and so on you know that's a whole big
problem but i still think that
people being shady with the results of
their research
is still the biggest problem there's
just not too many retractions
of it in machine learning because who
can ever reproduce someone else's paper
if you didn't get my numbers
you just did it wrong so what is the
real solution against
fake science it's probably hard to know
but i guess
an approach to a solution would be to
have some sort of a distributed
checking mechanism where you can
aggregate opinions
from all around the world about a given
topic and then sort of
look at everything and evaluate for
yourself rather than relying on a
centralized
committee to do it for you be that for
fake news or fake science or fake
anything i think that's the only way
forward because any centralized
institutions will
eventually get either corrupted or gamed
because they have some sort of scoring
system but i'm be interested
in what you have to say all of this is a
problem it's not exactly clear how we go
about
making this better can we even make it
better or can we just find
better ways to ignore the fake things
alright that was it from me
for this week's ml news i hope you had
fun
i hope you don't get replaced by a
machine anytime soon and most of all i
hope i don't get replaced by a machine
anytime soon so wish you a happy day and
[Music]
goodbye
you